willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung heute
haben wir wieder das begriffsnetz zuerst
aber jetzt kommen neue Begriffe dazu
jetzt wird ihr Horizont begrifflich
hoffentlich erweitert wenn sie mal
schauen das ist ja alles bekannt hier
ist vielleicht auch gar nicht schlecht
sich so ein bisschen zu überlegen wo
steht was ein Tipp ich habe das auch den
Tutorin Tutoren gesagt sie können mal zu
Übung gerne auf dem Tutorium an einem
Begriff ansetzen und dann mal erklären
wie man zu einem anderen Begriff kommt
also Begriff springen sozusagen das ist
gar nicht schlecht weil sie nämlich dann
die Begriffe auch im Verhältnis
bestimmen können gegen Begriffe ähnliche
Begriffe Begriffe die vorausgesetzt
werden müssen um was anderes zu erklären
zu bestimmen das ist ja auch eine
Dimension der Philosophie klare Begriff
Definition das heißt man muss einem
Begriff bestimmen können und bestimmen
kann man kein Begriff häufig auch am
besten im Kontext also dieser Begriff
verhält sich zu seinem Gegenbegriff so
es steht in einem Bereich von anderen
Begriffen hier in diesem
freiheitskontext das ist
Begriffsbestimmung dann ist ein weiteres
Thema was wir gesagt haben auch für die
Klausur wichtig gute Beispiele zu
entwickeln um was zu belegen um was zu
veranschaulichen vielleicht auch um ein
Problem klar hervor treten zu lassen
gute Beispiele und drittens für die
Philosophie ganz wichtig gute Argumente
pro und contra argumente sich auch
Einwände machen das ist auch mit diesen
Pro und Contra immer verbunden wenn ich
gut drohen kontra Argumente finde kann
ich auch meine eigene Argumentation
dadurch stärken dass ich nicht nur gute
Beispiele bringen nicht nur eine klare
Begrüßung habe sondern immer mir selbst
Einwände mache und darauf dann wieder
reagiert kann also diese drei Punkte
sind mir sehr wichtig dass die
rüberkommen im Rahmen dieser Vorlesung
jetzt sehen sie jetzt füllt sich die
rechte untere Seite ich habe leider kein
Platz mehr
und jetzt sehen Sie schon jetzt kommt
das böse und jetzt kommt was neues die
Folien finden Sie auch alle auf
Ilias jetzt habe ich hier eine
Abzweigung beim bösen da gibt es hier
eine privation eine Perversion man kann
das Böse als privation ich komme noch
genauer darauf zu sprechen ich nehme das
jetzt einfach mal weg als privation oder
als Perversion verstehen was das genau
ist werde ich heute noch ausführlich mit
ihm nicht nur diskutieren sondern auch
im Kontext von anderen Begriffen
erörtern dann haben wir noch hier die
drei neue ethische Position ich habe es
jetzt mal da rein gemacht aber weil sie
irgendwie in der Nähe von der
Normativität ihren Ort haben also hier
die Anthologie Tugend
ethikarismus die habe ich jetzt jemand
in diesem Bereich der armaturität
reingetan genau gesagt natürlich die
moralische Normativität hier auch um das
Gute und dieser Problem dieses Problem
von sein und sollen und des
naturalistischen fehlschlusses die
stehen natürlich auch allen diesen
Kontext also ich gehe deswegen nicht
näher auf die Ontologie tugenethik und
Utilitarismus ein eigentlich müsste ich
zu jeder dieser drei ethischen Position
mindestens eine eigene Sitzung machen
aber wir haben es ja nicht mit einer
Vorlesung in die Moralphilosophie zu tun
sondern nur als Anführungsstrichen eine
Vorlesung die die Grundbegriffe der
praktischen Philosophie einführen soll
und insofern glaube ich reicht dass wir
diskutieren diese drei ethischen
Position nur vor dem Hintergrund des
Problems des Guten der Normativität
alles andere kann uns davon hier leider
nicht mehr interessieren sein sie froh
es kommt ja nicht in der Klausur dran
sie können aber natürlich gern im
Tutorium dann darüber weiter diskutieren
jetzt gebe ich noch mal kurzen Rückblick
zu diesen drei ethischen Positionen die
sollten Sie kennen das wäre zum Beispiel
auch eine gute Frage des Chips ah dass
man die diese drei Position Aktion nennt
drei wichtige ethische Positionen und
dass man vielleicht auch Sie etwas
erklären kann das wäre eine gute Frage
des Typs a können meine Tutorien und
Tutoren gerne in unser begriffspool
aufnehmen falls die nicht eh schon drin
ist sie dürfen die ja auch einstellen
die Fragen den Begriff tun als wir sehen
die Ontologie die Pflicht Ethik die ist
jetzt eher an der Motivation an an der
Subjektivität an der Intention
im Verhältnis zur Handlung und der
Utilitarismus der schaut nicht so sehr
auf die Motivation die Gründe dahinter
stehen sondern auf die Konsequenzen und
er sagt er oder sie es geht um das
größte Glück
steht natürlich wieder die Frage wie als
PhilosophInnen und Philosophen wenn wir
jetzt Glück hören dann fragen wir sofort
kritisch was verstehst Du genau unter
Glück unter Lust unter Freude und Nutzen
und so muss man es dann auch tun und
will halt darauf auch geantwortet ich
bringe jetzt hier gerade nochmal von
Dirk dieses zentrale Zitat aus einer
Schrift über den Utilitarismus er sagt
also die Nützlichkeit und das Prinzip
des größten Glücks ist die Grundlage der
Moral nach seiner Theorie des
Utilitarismus unter Glück dabei Lust und
das frei sein von Unlust unter Unglück
Unlust und das Fehlen von lustig
verstanden jetzt kann man sich natürlich
fragen was ist jetzt genau Lust was ist
genau Glück und er hat selbst diesen
Einwand sich gemacht
man könnte jetzt ja denken wir sind
bloße
epikurea oder Hedonisten vielleicht
haben Sie schon mal dieses Wort gehört
häufig wird auch Hedonismus oder das
Wort Hedonist oder möglichst hin negativ
verwendet wenn sie gesagt bekommen sie
sind eine Hedonistin oder sie sind ein
Hedonist dann ist es in der Regel jetzt
nicht wirklich ein bösartiger Vorwurf an
sie aber vielleicht auch nicht gerade
ein Kompliment weil dann würde ihm
gesagt werden die sind eine Person die
nur nach Lust strebt die will nur Lust
haben nur Freude haben und alles andere
ist ihr eigentlich egal also da steckt
so ein bisschen der wo wird das Egoismus
dahinter und das ist natürlich wäre
natürlich genau gegenteiligen Sinne von
Müll deswegen muss er sagen es geht hier
um höhere Fähigkeiten die unsere Lust
hervorrufen und nicht bloß tierische
Gelüste da sehen sie wieder der
Unterschied Person menschliches Tier es
geht ihm um den Menschen als Person als
Wesen was höhere Fähigkeiten ausübt das
kann man sich natürlich genauer fragen
was für Fähigkeiten sind es als erster
Stelle kann man sie natürlich gegen
unsere Vernunft vernünftig aber könnte
auch denken einen Sinn für das schöne
den Geschmack
gehen wir mal wieder ein schönes Konzert
vielleicht auch ein Sinn für sportliche
Aktivitäten Konstanz Halbmarathon und so
kein diktiercamp auf die Idee freiwillig
Bill 20 Kilometer zu laufen muss doch eh
genug laufen ist doch froh wenn sie es
mal ausruhen kann also das sind alles
höhere Fähigkeiten Ästhetik Vernunft
Kultur alles was im kulturellen Kontext
im Gegensatz zur Natur zu verstehen ist
dem will Werte somit es geht also
letztendlich um wertmaximierung und
nicht um Lust Maximierung also die Lust
ist praktisch nur eine Folge davon dass
wir ein Verhältnis zu einem Wert
hergestellt haben wie diskutieren gleich
noch drüber das möchte ich nur mal hier
kurz zeigen und er bringt hier eben noch
dieses Zitat wo doch in der Wert
Bestimmung aller anderen Dinge nehmen
neben der Quantität auch die Qualität
Berücksichtigung finden also es geht ihm
nicht um den meisten Nutzen im Sinne der
Quantität möglichst viel möglichst
günstig oder wie auch immer
das ist ja praktisch nur quantitativ da
ist einfach kein tieferer Sinn dahinter
es geht um die Qualität vielleicht auch
um die Intensität um die Rationalität um
die Ästhetik also um die höheren Werte
die sich zeigen
Qualität und diese Werte sollen
vergrößert werden für die ganze
Gesellschaft dann würde mir sagen ist
unser Prinzip des untergitarismus
erfüllt und da können wir natürlich
treffend drüber diskutieren ob es hier
vielleicht doch noch ein paar Probleme
gibt die wir jetzt hier noch nicht
erörtert haben
also wir haben gesehen es gibt ja ein
Problem wie will man würde Fähigkeiten
genau bestimmen was sind höhere
Fähigkeiten im Gegensatz zu plus
tierischen Gelüsten können wir das
Objektiv bestimmen wie können wir
unterscheiden zwischen bloßer Quantität
und Qualität was ist das Kriterium um
Qualität zu ermessen sicherlich schwebt
er hier der Gedanke der Vernunft im
Hintergrund aber da müsste man jetzt
genau noch auf den Text eingehen darf
möchte ich nur Hinweisen wir haben noch
die Position der dontologie diskutiert
da ist die man kann im Hintergrund das
heißt es gibt nichts Gutes auf der Welt
was allein gut genannt werden könnte
ohne Einschränkung gut genannt werden
könnte unbedingt gut genannt werden
könnte dann sucht also das absolut gute
und nicht nur das relativ gute was für
zehn könnte was von manche vielleicht
gut ist manche finden daran los manche
nicht manche mögen es Kreuzworträtsel zu
lösen und ihre höheren Fähigkeiten
anzuwenden manche mögen es viele viele
auf den Seychellen manche lieber nicht
ist doch alles subjektiv könnte man
sagen und kann möchte jetzt etwas Gutes
finden was ohne Einschränkung also
absolut objektiv gut ist das sagte das
alleine ein guter Witz der bringt hier
verschiedene andere mögliche Kandidaten
für gut sein oder Tugenden zum Beispiel
Geschlossenheit Mut Beharrlichkeit
Vorsätze das nennt ihr Eigenschaften
Testament Temperaments man könnte es
auch und beides diesen Tugenden nennen
die sind gut aber sie können äußerst
böse gebraucht werden Gerechtigkeit
natürlich nicht Gerechtigkeit ist
intrinsisch gut Gerechtigkeit kann ich
nicht böse verwenden ist kann eigentlich
kein gerechten Verbrecher geben man
könnte sagen er teilt seine Beute
gerecht das ist dann relativ
Gerechtigkeit aber absolut ist es
natürlich nicht direkt wenn man alle
Umstände berücksichtigen also
Entschlossenheit ein Bankräuber kann
entschlossen sein und jetzt die Bank
überfallen er kann der herrlich sein im
Vorsatz er kann fünf Jahre lang überall
getütet haben das mögen alles
charaktertugenden sein aber sie sind
kompatibel mit Ausführung des unorischen
genauso Verstand und Witz was unter
Verstand ist muss man sich noch genauer
überlegen Urteilskraft genauso das ist
seine These und das sagt noch ihren
wichtigen Satz den ich einfach fetter
vorgehoben habe im Kontrast zu unter die
Tourismus der gute Wille ist nicht durch
das was er bewirkt oder ausrichtet
durch seine Tauglichkeit gut sondern
allein durch das wollen an sich und ein
solcher in einem Juwel der für sich
glänzt auch wenn er nicht zu einer
Handlung kommt es geht hier nur um die
Absicht nur um die Absicht die aufbetung
aller Mittel das ist wieder der
Unterschied zwischen Wille und Wunsch
ganz wichtige Unterscheidung eventuell
auch für die Klausur relevant diese
Unterscheidung machen kann bloßer Wunsch
wirklicher Wille denn der Aufbietung
aller mit
steht Harry Frankfurt hat das ganz
ähnlich definiert und selbst wenn es
nicht zu einer Handlung käme obwohl wir
eine Intention eine Absicht formiert
haben und es wirklich wollen alle unsere
Konzentration auf etwas denken und
trotzdem können wir die Handlung nicht
vollziehen weil irgendwann blöder Zufall
passiert oder irgendwas anderes was
nicht unserer Macht steht passiert und
die Handlung verhindern kann wäre das
dennoch gut zu nennen diese Wille auch
wenn er nicht seine Handlung führt und
hier sieht man eben das ist die
Konzentration nur auf den Willen auf die
Subjektivität auf die maximale
letztendlich die dahinter steht
hintereinander und nicht auf die
Handlung oder weitere handlungs Folgen
deswegen ist die Biologie
konsequentialismus und den Utilitarismus
auf eine Weise sind gegengesetzt wir
haben noch die Tugend diskutiert ist
sondern die komischen der spricht der
vom rechts rechts Maß was das Gute als
du auszeichnet und er bringt eben zum
Beispiel
[Musik]
verschiedene Google den
wo man die Mitte finden muss also zum
Beispiel die
Tapferkeit die muss unterschieden werden
von durch und oder Feigheit
vollkühlenheit es geht um die Rechte
Mitte genauso soll man Lust nur nach
Maßen genießen also wieder zügellos noch
sauerteppich also griesgrämig oder
puritanisch oder ich weiß nicht was soll
die richtige finden natürlich steht
jetzt die Frage wie man direkt die Mitte
findet er sagt die wird durch unsere
Vernunft bestimmt wie ein kluger Mensch
diese Mitte zu bestimmen
pflegt was geht also Urteilskraft und es
geht um Situationen wir können das nicht
absolut sagen sie müssen immer für das
jeweilige Individuum für die jeweilige
Situation diese Rechte Mitte mit unserer
Urteilskraft aus Mittel sozusagen und
deswegen ist die Tugend zwar ihren
wesensbegriff nach die Mitte aber
normativ gesehen ist natürlich die
Tugend nichts
mittelmäßiges das wäre ja auch irgendwie
seltsam wenn die Tugend als Mitte im
Sinne der Mittelmäßigkeit definiert
wurde ist natürlich normativ zu
definieren als das Äußerste und beste
was wir tun können
ich denke dass diese unterscheiden recht
klar ist und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen um
Sie ein bisschen hier wieder zu
aktivieren die Möglichkeit geben ihre
natürlich begründete Meinung hier auch
die abzugeben jetzt frage ich sie mal
natürlich gefragt aber welche Position
ich ethische Position halten Sie am
besten einen für das Gute zu bestimmen
geht die Umfrage oder muss ich sie noch
aktivieren also
Utilitarismus deontologie oder Tugend
welche dieser
Positionen scheint ihnen die am besten
geeignete zu sein wir können natürlich
noch darüber diskutieren ob man
vielleicht nicht einen Mix aus
verschiedenen Ansätzen entwickeln muss
aber diese Frage möchte erstmal so
stellen und wir schauen jetzt gleich die
Auswertung an
ja die
Abstimmung hat ergeben dass
aristotelespunktetik dass die besonders
attraktiv von den Teilnehmern wird sie
hat genauso viele Stimmen bekommen 50%
Punkte wie die anderen beiden
konkurrierenden
Position der autologie und unter die
Terrorismus man kann sie natürlich
darüber streiten
Mischform erstellen kann eine
deontologie ethischen ansetzen ein
Utilitarismus mit die unterologischen
Ansätzen wo man die Interessen
berücksichtigt sowas Würde des Menschen
dass man Menschen nicht gegeneinander
abrechnen darf wie es in manchen
Beispielen geschildert wird aber man
kann hier schön modifizieren
Zwischenformen das war natürlich wieder
eine provokative Frage
ausgehen aber ich finde das Votum sehr
interessant und alles gewonnen und
deswegen lohnt es sich auch immer auf
den ethischen Naturalismus einzugehen
der ist der Antritt als ein Neo
Aristotelismus für die paar food die
Natur des Guten natural goodness auch
ihr interessant und sie sagt neben mir
bestimmt das Gute in der Art durch die
Art und Weise wie wir überleben urteilen
oder nach
denken also es gibt hier eine große
strukturelle
urteilsgleichheitsstrukturelle
Gleichheit
können wir moralischen Normativität das
moralisch gute nicht nur das Gut
insgesamt durch Bezug auf den Begriff
des Lebens
natürlichen Lebens erklären ist neben
ein normativer begriff ich habe es schon
mal darauf hingewiesen es gibt solche
Begriffe die eigenen sich um auch diesen
Übergang vom sein zum sollen irgendwie
zu bewältigen ich hatte schon mal gesagt
die Rationalität und die Vernunft ist so
eine Kandidatin dann der Lebensbegriff
für dich auch der Natur Begriff oder die
Teleologie sind solche Begriffe die
immer wieder versucht wurden da ein zu
füllen in diese Kluft zwischen sein soll
und diesen Übergang herzustellen aber
kann sie noch andere Begriffe überlegen
und sie sagt sie denkt das
Zuschreibungen von gut ausnahmslos auf
die Welt der Liebe gewesen also auch
Pflanzen Tiere Menschen bezogen und das
die Vorstellung von gut oder schlecht
ohne den Begriff des Lebens Inhalt wäre
das wird natürlich immer nur bekannten
streiten der würde sagen gute solange
ein guter Wille ich kann nicht über
natürliche Dinge gut im Sinne des Guten
sprechen warum nicht weil es sich
hierbei als sonst um ein ja
naturalistischen Fehlschluss handeln
würde diesem Sinne oder es wäre keine
Normativität in natürlich deshalb kann
wir hatten ein Zitat gelesen die Natur
kennt keinen Sonnenuntergang es gibt
keine Normativität in der Natur da
gibt's nur ein ist nur Kausalität früher
oder später Ursache Wirkung aber nicht
ein Normativität und selbst wenn wir
teleologisch also zweckmäßig über die
Natur sprechen können wir das nicht
objektiv erkennen sondern das beschreibt
uns eine Art und Weise über die Natur zu
reflektieren Urteil aber auch nicht
unsere objektive Erkenntnis
jetzt sagt sie die Moralphilosophie ist
nicht anderes als ein Zweig eine
Untersuchung des Guten das in einer
besonderen und allgemeinen weil zu
menschlichen Leben gehört also die ist
hier
Stichpunkt jetzt bringt sie den Begriff
des Defekts ins Spiel und das ist
natürlich dann eine Verbindung zum
Begriff des Bösen oder schlechten der
heute im Zentrum stehen soll sie spricht
von einem Trittbrett fahrenden Golfen
interessantes Beispiel ein Wolf der
nicht mit an der Jagd teilnimmt aber
dennoch die die jagte deutsche Frist
genauso eine Biene die eine Nektarquelle
entdeckt aber den anderen nicht deren
Ort mitteilen könnte man sagen es sind
doch egoistische Lebewesen natürlich
kann man sowas diesen Wesen nicht zu
schreiben
irgendwas nicht in Ordnung wir haben im
Endeffekt nämlich wenn Sie Ihren Wesen
gemäß handeln würde oder sich verhalten
würde ihre Wesen gemäß oder ist
natürlich
Hintergrund Essenz das Lesen eines
Lebewesen die Art artgemäß sich
verhalten würden dann würden sie andere
leben ihre mit Lebewesen darauf
hinweisen und es geht also ein Defekt
und daran setzt sie an die spricht von
Muster natürlicher Normativität und
fragt ob wir dieselbe urteilsstruktur
finden wenn wir von Pflanzen Tieren
Ihren defekten oder ihre Vorzügen
sprechen und wenn wir von der Bewertung
des Willens sprechen ob es hier eine
urteilsstruktur gibt die analoge sind
die begabt das ja jetzt können wir hier
noch mal kurz drüber diskutieren über
food ob ihnen das einleuchtet oder ob
sie hier vielleicht noch ein paar
Rückfragen haben dazu ist jetzt gelegen
jetzt wollen wir übergehen zum
eigentlichen Thema der heutigen
Vorlesung sie ahnen es schon es geht um
nichts Geringeres als um das moralisch
oder nicht moralisch böse oder schlechte
wir haben ein paar Fragen die
unterscheidet sich das bloß schlechte
von moralisch bösen es gibt natürlich
hier wie beim guten ganz verschiedene
Bedeutungen das ist ein Begriff der ist
normativ schlecht und Böse das ist schon
mal klar ja das ist irgendwie das soll
nicht sein warum das Böse oder schlechte
nicht sein soll das ist eine
interessante Frage aber es ist ein
normativer Begriff ähnlich wie
Ungerechtigkeit
ist das Böse moralisch böse als
natürlicher defekt oder als Defekt zu
verstehen das ist der Bezug zu Philippa
food zu dem trittbrettfahrenden und der
egoistischen Biene
sind die böse oder ist handeln was
analog dazu zu verstehen ist von
menschlichen Personen Böse zu nennen
wenn es defekt ist und nicht unsere
menschlichen Art entspringt da müssen
wir einfach mal überlegen und dann eine
ganz spannende Frage wie verhält sich
das Böse zu unserer Vernunft und auch
dazu wird es nachher wieder eine Umfrage
geben
die ich dann bei Zeit noch starten will
ich möchte sie ganz kurz auf ein Buch
von mir hinweisen das werde ich dann
auch auf Ilias stellen falls es
interessiert Theorien des Bösen
gibt jetzt auch bald ein Hörbuch davon
will hier gar nichts groß Werbung machen
und
da habe ich natürlich alles genau
beschrieben
und
jetzt gibt es zwei Bedeutungen von böse
gibt einmal das natürliche übel
das nennt man der Tradition das malung
Physikum das ist ganz wichtig diese
Unterscheidung zu wissen das wären zum
Beispiel Krankheiten defekte oder
sonstige Schwächen ja als wenn ich
irgendwie jetzt ich weiß nicht mir das
Bein gebrochen hat oder sowas oder
irgendwie Corona mal wieder hat ne dann
ist es vielleicht Böse zu nennen kann
man böse nennen Kinder sprechen manchmal
von etwas das böse sein wenn es ihm weh
tut da Schmerzen ist Kinder sprechen da
häufig nicht im moralischen sind aber
gemeint ist damit einfach schlecht und
es ist etwas was uns zu stößt und wo
hinter sich eigentlich bei Licht
betrachtet eine böse Absichten verbirgt
wenn ich Corona habe es sei denn ich
wurde bewusst mit Corona infiziert weil
mein bester Freund wusste dass der
Corona hat
aber keine Maske angezogen hat und mir
ins Gesicht gehustet hat gut dann kann
ich sagen Corona ist jetzt nicht nur
irgendwie so ein malum Physikum auch
natürlich aber dahinter verbirgt sich
was anderes nämlich das malumorale das
moralische übel
da sind Beispiele Mord Diebstahl
Missgunst also der bösartige Neid ist
natürlich jetzt tautologisch ne aber
auch Schadenfreude solche Dinge die z.B
Aristoteles als innen drin sich schlecht
bezeichnen also Schadenfreude kann in
gar keiner Situation gut sein genauso
wie Gerechtigkeit in keiner Situation
schlecht sein kann das intensische
intrinsische gute oder schlechte im
Sinne des moralischen Phänomene und sie
sehen den Unterschied zwischen diesen
zwei Formen des Bösen wenn man so will
das moralische übel das ist bewusst
verursacht dahinter steckt eine
Motivation eine böse Absicht die bewusst
etwas
Böses will die bewusst Schmerzen Schaden
vielleicht auch alle diese Formen des
malums Physikum verursachen möchte ich
uns defekte
vermitteln will in dem irgendwie uns ein
Leid angetan wird das ist aber
willentlich das ist bewusst getan
während das natürlich übel zu denkt man
zumindest meistens eben nicht bewusst
eingesetzt wurde manchmal hat man früher
oder man tut man das auch dass man
natürlich überall als Strafe für
eine vergangene schlechte Handlung sich
überlegt oder rationalisiert also eine
Strafe schlechtes Karma obwohl beim
Karma da kenne ich zu wenig aus ob da
wirklich eine Intention dahinter liegt
aber eine Strafe eine höheren Distanz
hat man sich früher häufig so
vorgestellt dass die in Form einer
Krankheit oder sonstigen Schwächen und
Effekten stattfand also man neigt immer
dazu selbst das natürlich übel irgendwie
intentional also bewusst war sich zu
erklären aber streng gesehen kann man
sagen das sind einfach Krankheiten
defekten die passieren so das kann auch
sein ein mit theoretisch stürzt hier ein
ich werde von Blitz getroffen das ist
ein Mahlow
Physiker natürliches Übel der Blitz
wollte mir natürlich keinen nicht mit
Absicht irgendwas böses Tun anders sieht
es aus beim Wort Diebstahl und Schaden
das ist schon mal eine ganz wichtige
Unterscheidung ich denke die ist
intuitiv
eingängig ja ich glaube da kann man
sicherlich auch noch ein bisschen drüber
diskutieren aber ich gehe jetzt erstmal
weiter
wenn man jetzt jetzt uns nur auf das
malumorale
als nur auf das moralische übel was in
meinen Augen philosophisch interessanter
ist als nur das ballungsrisiko wir
könnten jetzt natürlich hier eine
Vorlesung über Pathologie machen bin
aber kein Medizinprofessor dann müssten
sie in die Medizinische Fakultät gibt es
überhaupt Medizin in Konstanz gibt's gar
nicht gell dann müssten irgendwie eine
Biologin ein Biologen fragen der sich
mit Pathologie auskennt und wir müssten
nach Zürich oder Freiburg oder irgendein
Universität die Medizin anbietet
vielleicht bietet der Konstanz bald mal
Medizin an ich habe keine Ahnung aber
wenn wir was mehr über das Physikum über
das physische übel rausfinden wollten
müssten wir uns z.B mit der Pathologie
befassen ja da würde uns dann erzählt
werden wie eine Krebszelle funktioniert
wie ein Krebs funktioniert was für fiese
Strategien die Krankheit hat ja das sind
ja sehr ja heimtückische Krankheiten er
hat sich tarnen die versteckt wuchern
und dann plötzlich irgendwelchen das
kann man alles tatsächlich auch
irgendwie böse nennen nur wer ist das
kein moralischer Kontext den man zum
Beispiel Krebserkrankung diskutieren
wird dann müsste man die Pathologie
sagen es wäre interessant auch
sicherlich philosophisch aber noch
interessanter glaube ich ist eine
Analyse des moralisch bösen weil
dahinter sich natürlich Intentionen
verbirgt dahinter verbirgt sich
menschliche Subjektivität dahinter
verbergen sich Handlungen das verbirgt
sich auch nicht hinter natürlichen übel
es sei denn man würde eine Krankheit als
Handlung bezeichnen oder irgendwelche
Krebszellen als Handelnde Akteure
Akteurin aber das halte ich für etwas
unpassend das heißt wir konzentrieren
uns aufs moralisch böse auf zwei
Auffassung des moralisch bösen nachdem
wir schon zuvor zwei Auffassung des
Bösen oder schlechten differenziert
hatten schauen wir jetzt uns nur eine
Form davon an nämlich das mal um alle es
gibt die privat
erinnert sich noch an das Begriffs Netz
ich habe dabei den bösen so zwei
Abzweigung gemacht Privatperson
und das will ich jetzt erklären die
privationstheorie des moralisch bösen
sagt das Böse ist nur ein Mangel am gut
also praktisch das weniger gute
im Bösen ist das Gute die gute Anlage
nicht verwirklicht nicht ganz
verwirklichen das ist einfach ein Defekt
eine privation eine Beraubung des Guten
alles was nicht ganz gut ist was weniger
gut ist das ist dementsprechend schlecht
oder böse moralisch gesehen
die privationstheorie ich gebe Ihnen
noch ein Beispiel zum Beispiel Trägheit
und Faulheit das Gute zu tun
bin einfach zu trägig ich habe nicht die
Kraft dazu keine Lust ich bin
unmotiviert ja so könnte man sich das
zum Beispiel vorstellen ja in einer
Trägheit das Problem ist
da kommen noch genau drauf zu sprechen
dann gibt es auf der anderen Seite die
perversionstheorie die sagt das böses
eine Umkehrung eine Perversion das heißt
lateinisch Latein
Umkehrung der guten Ordnung also im
Bösen so die andere erfassen die
perversionstheorie da stelle ich die
moralische Ordnung auf den Kopf es ist
kein Mangel sondern das ist mehr noch
das ist ich bin hier der Gute und die
geltenden Gesetze die gelten ich stelle
mich über die Allgemeinheit ne hier
gibt's ein Beispiel
Rationalisierung einer unmoralischen
Hand eine eigentlich unmoralischen
Handlung als gerecht das ist ein
Beispiel für die Perversion des Bösen
warum weil ich hier ein ganz anderen
normativen Maßstab ins Spiel bringen und
die eigentliche Ordnung
umkehren also ich erhebe meine
privatmoral zur allgemeingültigen Moral
des sie sehen da finden andere ist eine
andere Perspektive auf das Böse hier
möchte ich mal ganz kurz anhalten und
mit ihnen darüber diskutieren dass wir
dieses Verständnis noch weiter vertiefen
können
ja wir haben gesehen diese zwei Theorien
die haben Vor und Nachteilen wir wollen
jetzt mal hier noch kurz ein Beispiel
einer präventionstheorie hier anbringen
nämlich von Plotin einem
antiken spät antiken Philosophen genau
genommen der war natürlich von Platon
stark beeinflusst und er hat ein Werk
geschrieben die Nähte vielleicht werden
die hier auch mal Konstanz Angeboten ich
glaube es eher nicht aber es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen hat und er sagt folgendes
zum Thema privatration des Bösen die
Natur der Körper als so weit sie an der
Materie Teil hat ist böse denn die haben
den sie haben eine nicht wahrhafte Form
sind des Lebens beraubt sie vernichten
sich gegenseitig durch die von ihnen
ausgehenden ungeordnete Bewegung sie
hemmen die Seelen ihre eigentümlichen
Tätigkeit als ewig fließend fliehen sie
die Wesenheit
die Seele aber ist nicht an sich böse
auch nicht jede bösen aber welches ist
die böse Seele diejenige sagt Platon
welches sich einen Menschen dienstbar
gemacht hat dem von Natur die
Schlechtigkeit der Seele Angeboten ist
in dem die unvernünftige Form der Seele
das Böse aufnimmt und jetzt kommt
nämlich Maßlosigkeit
Übermaß Mangel aus denen auch
Zügellosigkeit und Feigheit und die
sonstige Schlechtigkeit der Seele stammt
unfreiwillige Leidenschaften welche
falsche Meinung veranlassen das für das
verschlecht und gut zu halten wovor sie
fliegt und wonach sie strebt
das ist ein interessantes Zitat über das
wir jetzt mal ganz kurz noch sprechen
wollen bevor wir uns dann mit der
perversionstheorie anhand eines Zitats
auseinandersetzen
ja wir haben gesehen es gibt eine
reichhaltige Tradition über das Böse
oben rechts im Youtube-Video mache ich
einen Link zur Playlist meines Seminars
Theorien des Bösen vom letzten Semester
rein wo man das noch mal allen Details
historisch nachvollziehen kann jetzt
gebe ich ein Beispiel zu Perversion des
Bösen und zwar ist hier für mich der
Bezugspunkt Immanuel kann in seiner
religionsschrift die Religion innerhalb
der Grenzen Diagnose von uns was sagt
der was sagt die Bösartigkeit
miziositas gravitas oder wenn man lieber
will die Verderbtheit Korruption des
menschlichen Herzens ist der Hand der
Willkür zu Maximen die Triebfeder aus
dem moralischen Gesetz andern nicht
moralischen nachzusetzen sie kann auch
die jetzt kommt Verkehrtheit perversitat
des menschlichen Herzens heißen weil sie
die sittliche Ordnung in Anziehung der
Trieb will also der Motivation
freien Willkür umkehrt damit sagt
kann das Böse muss als Perversion
verstanden werden weil ich im Bösen die
moralische Triebfeder nämlich die
Achtung das was gute Motiv ist sind den
schlechten Motiven Nachsätze also ich
ordne individuelle egoistische Motive
den eigentlich Motiven eigentlich
moralischen Motiven zum Beispiel der
Achtung über ein Beispiel wäre zum
Beispiel der Neid im Neid Orden ich mein
Egoismus eigentlich dem Respekt vor
anderen Personen über also ich
konstruiere mir hier so eine privaten
Moral und setze meine egoistischen
individuellen trieb fehlen
Motivationsgründe man könnte auch von
Bewegung motivationalen Gründen sprechen
Stichwort Gründe wieder ersetzt sich den
moralischen Gründen voran ich drehe die
Ordnung um ich orientiere mich nicht an
den eigentlichen geboten dem Sitten
gesetzt nicht entziehe mich die sind
Gebot wie ich mich dann entziehen kann
das ist wieder eine spannende Frage
Stichwort Rationalisierung aber
natürlich auch Stichwort Selbsttäuschung
und da haben wir eine eigene Sitzung
dann noch dazu der jetzt möchte ich noch
mal ganz kurz zum Schluss die Frage
aufwerfen hatten wir auch schon wer oder
was ist eigentlich böse moralisch sind
es kollektive Personen soziale
Strukturen können die moralisch böse
genannt werden können sind es
individuelle Personen also wie Sie und
ich das wäre aber irgendwie auch schlimm
wenn jeder von uns oder wenn ich jetzt
hier nur böse wäre eine böse Person ein
böses Wesen hätte würde mich ein
bisschen unwohl fühlen sind jetzt meine
Handlung also manche Handlung von mir
sind böse aber nicht alle weil ich ja
kein böses lesen habe ich mir keine böse
Person oder können böse eigentlich nur
maximal meine maximum Intentionen
genannt werden das wäre eine
kantianische Auffassung ganz analog zum
Guten solange ein guter Wille böse
moralisch gesehen ist allein ein böser
Wille und die Bösen Hand entspringen
erst aus diesem Willen sie sind also
fundiert und alles weitere auch darüber
kann man wirklich trefflich streiten wie
man das gesehen hat wollen wir den
nächsten Sitzung fortführen wir haben
jetzt nicht mehr viel Zeit und jetzt
kann man sich verschiedene Fragen
stellen noch zu Vernunft ist das Böse
rational ist das Böse vernünftig wie
verhält sich das moralisch Böse zu
Vernunft da gibt es eben auch natürlich
zwei Auffassungen einmal gemäß der
privationsthese des böse ist nicht nur
ein Mangel am guten sondern auch ein
Mangel an Vernunft Beispiel das Böse
entspringt aus einem Denkfehler ja oder
aus einer rationalen Unordnung
anderes Beispiel das Böse entspricht
nicht entspringt entspringt aus
Willensschwäche nächste wichtiger
Begriff alle Gründe sprechen für X aber
ich tue trotzdem y können wir uns so das
Böse vorstellen
oder man könnte auch sagen dass böse
entspringt unkontrollierten Neigungen
und trieben im Bösen gehen einfach die
Triebe mit mir durch ich habe mich nicht
mehr unter Kontrolle deswegen bestelle
ich eine Person ich wurde überwältigt
von meinem niederen Instinkten und mein
trieben meine Gier nach Geld sowas ja
hier ist ein Problem nämlich die diese
privilegation ist uns dann nicht mehr
ohne weiteres zurechenbar wenn ich im
Bösen nach der privatisationstheorie ein
Mangel an Vernunft habe weil die Neigung
mit mir durchgegangen sind meine hat dir
meine Neigung meine hat mich überwältigt
dann kann ich das eigentlich nicht mehr
richtig mir zu rechnen da wurde ich von
meinen niederen Instinkten überrumpelt
da war ich gar nicht mehr Hermann selbst
wir haben mal ein Problem dazu Rechnung
wir werden noch in einer nächste Sitzung
auf das Problem der Zurechnung zu
sprechen kommen
wenn wir jetzt aber auf der anderen
Seite sagen das Böse besteht einem
speziellen Gebrauch der Vernunft einem
perversen Vernunft gebraucht also wenn
wir sagen die Rationalität ist im Bösen
enthalten und nicht nur Mangel am
Rationalität zum Beispiel durch
einsatzinstrumenteller Vernunft bei
einem Banküberfall auch böse
bankräuberinnen und Bankräuber streng
ihre von uns an das ist bekannt sonst
würden die keinen Cent stehen
oder wenn ich finde ich noch ein
besseres Beispiel wenn ich meine
Missgunst als gerechtfertigte Empörung
rationalisiere wenn ich also meine
beitrationalisiere dann setzt sich da
meine Vernunft ein und zwar auf eine
sehr komplexe und manchmal auch sehr
sexisticated
das Problem ist natürlich wieder
Rationalität scheint intrinsisch
irgendwie normativ zu sein also
Rationalität scheint irgendwie aufs gute
gerichtet zu sein auch irgendwie aufs
moralisch Güte wie kann dann diese
eigentlich schwach normative Vernunft
dieses Vermögen fürs böse gebraucht
werden ja
das möchte ich Ihnen jetzt einfach nur
zum Nachdenken mitgeben und wir werden
dann der nächsten Sitzung drüber
diskutieren ob das moralisch böse eher
ein privation oder eine Perversion ist
sie haben jetzt noch genügend Zeit um
sich das in aller Ruhe zu überlegen dann
wünsche ich Ihnen noch eine schöne best
Woche bis zur nächsten Sitzung